tras la detención del ex procurador
general jesús murillo karam por su
presunta participación en el caso de los
43 estudiantes desaparecidos de la
víctima para el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador aseguró que no habrá
impunidad para las personas culpables y
que el estado ha dejado de ser el
principal violador de derechos humanos
se pensaba
qué
quién es
cometían delitos
en nombre del estado
gozaban de impunidad
y eso
ya se terminó
la prisión preventiva de jesús murió que
fue impuesta para garantizar su
comparecencia en una audiencia judicial
del miércoles donde se determinará si
será juzgado por cargos relacionados con
el caso
el grupo de expertos encomendados por la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos para estudiar la desaparición de
los 43 estudiantes solicitó este lunes
acceso a todas las pruebas del informe
que presentó la semana pasada el
gobierno
se va a dañar se va a manchar
el ejército o las fuerzas armadas no
si se mancha
si
hay complicidad
cuestionado sobre la posibilidad de
detener al ex presidente enrique peña
nieto el mandatario andrés manuel lópez
obrador indicó que la fiscalía general
de la república o los jueces
determinarán si hay otros involucrados